Prime Minister tsipras assured us of
Greece's services seriousness and
willingness to work constructively if
the last hours has have shown we can see
all parties fully committed to finding a
solution the new Greek proposals to the
three institutions are a positive step
for what according to the initial
assessment of the institution's they
will be further a first over the coming
hours I am confident that you will group
on next Wednesday will produce results
to be submitted to the European Council
on Thursday I am convinced that it is
not only our intention to finalize
finalize the decision making process
this week we will finalize the process
this week we will continue to work on
the basis of a new proposal which is
certainly more comprehensive and
includes much more details than what we
had seen but it's still like specificity
it is still short of everything that
should be expected so there will be room
for negotiation room for work and
hopefully we will be constructive in a
very short period of time so we're short
on time no hard work